eh bien, lançons un défi folliculaire
après vous, eh bien, je vais devoir
me raser la tête pour ce film à un
moment donné pour être honnête avec vous, c'est
quelque chose qui me passionne pour Patrick,
c'est Bryan Singer et James McAvoy - pour
obtenir Patrick via le visage  nous sommes sur le point
de raser les cheveux de James c'est le moment
mon pote nous avons encore ton honneur la
nature emblématique de la première érection je suis content d'
arriver enfin à cette destination
quelle est ma main sur moi quel pote on y
va cowboy
oh oui toi  allez pour un mohawk d'accord merci
bébé
qu'en est-il ici juste que gardez le
mulet avec chaque mèche de cheveux qui
laisse tomber mon pouvoir augmente j'ai en
fait ouais mais c'est la première fois que
je le fais c'est fini je
comprends enfin quoi  c'est comme être utilisé
très bien probablement le moment encore
plus que dans Days of Future passé mais j'avais l'
impression qu'il passait le relais,
il est comme passer les Clippers les gars
oh merci Patrick Santa Sara Patrick
Stewart